me rapport d'activités de la commission
informatique et libertés il y a deux ans
et qui pour la circonstance a décidé de
décentraliser ses activités elle s'est
rendue aujourd'hui à lille dans une
région où l'ordinateur a déjà beaucoup
de poids sommes tout près des grandes
maisons de vente par correspondance
bernard pradines eaux étaient sur place
la commission informatique et liberté
qui n'a pas d'équivalent à l'étranger
veut éviter aux français la tyrannie de
l'ordinateur l'informatique ne doit pas
porter atteinte à la vie privée ni aux
libertés individuelles ou publiques
la mission essentielle de la commission
et donc de contrôler tous les fichiers
informatisés qui existe est de donner un
avis sur la création de nouveaux or on
compte actuellement 250 milles fichiers
au moins public ou privé ceux de l'edf
de la police de la sécurité sociale des
pentes des fichiers de la vente par
correspondance les cartes grises des
hôpitaux
il y a même un commerce florissant de
ces fichiers entre sociétés plus
l'ordinateur frontières d'informations
sur vous et votre famille
plus les risques de vous classer en bon
ou mauvais citoyen existe
un certain nombre d'utilisateurs de
l'informatique rassemble des
informations sans savoir à quoi elles
serviront et il est possible qu'un jour
ces informations puissent être
préjudiciable à vue privée ou aux
libertés ainsi il y a un projet
concernant les cartes électroniques de
paiement bien quand ce système sera au
point il est évident qu'il sera possible
de suivre à la trace les détenteurs de
cette carte on saura que tel jour à
telle heure il aura réalisé était
l'achat à tel endroit
or il y à une liberté fondamentale et
avec elle les français puisque d'autres
sont attachés à la liberté d'aller et
venir
la commission a déjà donné plusieurs
avis elle a fait infléchir certains
projets administratif à propos des
douanes du téléphone du casier
judiciaire de la carte d'identité unique
elle a donc un poids politique son
premier rapport aujourd'hui prouve
qu'elle existe et que son travail ne
fait que commencer
la commission informatique et libertés
voudrait maintenant défendre mieux
encore et libertés publiques comme la
liberté d'expression où la liberté du
travail
la maîtrise de l'ordinateur est l'une
des conditions de la solidarité entre
les citoyens à l'étranger toujours